[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo programa de medio
ambiente en France 24 yo soy María Clara
calle Pakistán padece las peores
inundaciones de su historia que
paradójicamente comenzaron justo después
de la peor ola de calor que ha habido
marzo y abril fueron sucesivamente los
meses más calurosos en jacobab
catalogada por muchos como la ciudad más
caliente del mundo la temperatura superó
los 50 grados celsius y hoy está bajo el
agua por las lluvias monzónicas que
comenzaron en junio lluvias que han
golpeado a gran parte del territorio
literalmente un tercio de Pakistán está
bajo el agua ahora lo que supera
cualquier límite cualquier Barrera del
pasado nunca hemos visto algo así
iba incluso la super inundaciones de
2010 que literalmente arrasaron con la
mitad del país fueron mejores que esto
son las provincias más afectadas por las
lluvias monzónicas como lo vemos en el
mapa los años se han concentrado en
punjab y encint donde está karachi la
ciudad más grande del país es una
muestra de los extremos del clima que
padece Pakistán desde 1959 el país ha
emitido tan solo el 0,4% de los gases
que contaminan la tierra y a pesar de
esto es el octavo más afectado por los
climas extremos según el promedio de
eventos que hubo entre 2010 y 2019 y su
nivel de daños el índice de riesgo
climático lo encabezan Puerto Rico
myanmar y Haití y también incluyó más
naciones de sudeste asiático como
Tailandia
el ranking demuestra como los países en
desarrollo son los más golpeados por la
crisis climática y no solo porque son
más vulnerables sino porque además
tienen menos capacidad económica para
hacerle frente a los estragos por eso
aunque los desastres naturales dejan más
pérdidas monetarias en los países ricos
en las Naciones en desarrollo el clima
deja más muertos y miseria concretamente
en Pakistán la sequía extrema y las
inundaciones históricas dañaron tantos
cultivos que la inseguridad alimentaria
creció al punto que organismos
internacionales le pidieron a India el
Antiguo rival de los pakistaníes que
levanten las restricciones de exportar
comida y el desbalance entre los países
ricos y los menos desarrollados también
se vio cuando falló el tratado de los
océanos
168 estados negociaron durante dos
semanas en las oficinas de la ONU en
Nueva York y no lograron el primer
acuerdo vinculante que protegería las
aguas de altamar como ya lo explicamos
antes en un programa previo el impacto
pretendía establecer áreas protegidas
donde no se pudiera pescar y también
compartir el conocimiento científico Que
surge de estudiar este ecosistema pero
los países que explotan por ejemplo
cobalto en esas aguas se opusieron este
es uno de los elementos principales del
desarrollo tecnológico y tampoco votaron
a favor Las Naciones donde hay grandes
pesqueras de mar abierto los países
caribeños sostienen por su parte que los
estados más ricos llegaron únicamente
Durante los últimos días de la discusión
pero no todas las noticias son malas y
en México hay un gran ejemplo ambiental
las comunidades del Norte del país
llevan 40 años desarrollando exitosas
empresas dedicadas al aprovechamiento
forestal en donde está la madera en sus
10,5 millones de hectáreas de bosques
Sin desperdiciar ninguna de las ramas
que sobran Andrés Suárez Jaramillo y
Aurora bayud nos cuentan la historia
en otros bosques el trabajo terminaría
aquí el tronco Z la se vende a una
Aserradero y las ramas quedan
desperdigadas por el suelo pero en este
predio privado de topia en el estado
mexicano de Durango se aprovecha de cada
pedazo del árbol si no se tiene cuidado
con el manejo de los perdicios de los
desperdicios Pues igual en caso de un
incendio este el daño es mayor verdad
así está localizado tal vez dañe esta
parte aquí un arbolado pero no daña
aquella
estos montículos de ramas también sirven
para no erosionar el suelo y retener el
agua en una región que padece
frecuentemente de sequías exacerbadas
con esto queda terminado Sí y vamos al
siguiente
seguimos con el tronco a unos kilómetros
del Bosque en esa empresa del municipio
de Santiago Papasquiaro la palabra
desecho tampoco existe
ya tenemos la Consigna El reto de cada
vez más ir buscando Qué hacer qué mayor
valor agregado dale a nuestros residuos
en este momento para nosotros este es
nuestro mejor aprovechamiento en
efectivo
en 2019 la fábrica se convirtió en la
primera empresa forestal mexicana en ser
totalmente autosuficiente
energéticamente gracias a una Caldera de
bioenergía que carbura con residuos de
madera que no trabajamos aquí no se
calienta nada no se va la lavadora nada
ahí adentro pero el aprovechamiento de
estos desechos no paraáis esta ceniza le
hemos hecho análisis químicos para
utilizarla como complemento a nuestro
sustrato para la producción de planta
mezclada con residuos de otras áreas de
la empresa forma un compost que se
utiliza para la reforestación
pero no solamente al lado de la fábrica
también se cultiva orgullosamente maíz
y con este tipo de fertilizante
básicamente se han desarrollado esta
esta planta y aquí podemos ver que ya
tiene un elote
quizás buenas prácticas llevaron el
estado a tener el 47% de la superficie
forestal certificada del país bajo
estándares internacionales del Forest to
workship cancel los cuales garantizan
que se aprovecha la madera sin dañar el
bosque
y con este gran ejemplo de México Nos
despedimos pueden ver más programas
ambientales en francés 24.com
[Música]